you said that you went to where'd you go
did you go to the West Bank our plan was
really to shoot between Haifa Tel Aviv
and the West Bank when we were there we
weren't able to actually shoot in the
West Bank there was this um really kind
of just horrible thing that happened
this journalist Sharina was killed you
know and that happened while you were
there or just before you went there on
our locations on your oh Jesus oh wow
the fact that we got to go it look it
was it was unbelievable I mean it was we
were there for that massive event it
shifted a lot of our shooting I think
there was a few American Crew and then
we had our Palestinian crew and we were
in the middle of Jerusalem and we went
to a funeral and this journalist who got
killed
um is Christian and so so it's so it's
like we're at a church in Jerusalem with
this really just diverse group of people
and you know because there's Americans
there American Jewish uh crew and and
American Muslims and and Palestinian
Christians and and
um you know Christians in his Israel and
it's like I think everyone kind of
walked away especially when you go there
and and you've yeah yeah we shot a show
there and uh it was fascinating because
we shot first in Tel Aviv yeah and then
we went to Jerusalem and what I remember
very clearly is we had our our team that
was Israeli and then we went over to
shoot in Jerusalem that the teams had to
shift over so it's different security
because they need to be Palestinian and
it was all handled it's crazy because
all you've ever heard yeah is this
amazing horrible conflict that no one
can seem to figure out and then this was
just okay we're gonna stop here and then
these guys are going to take over hey
guys yep okay thank you very much and
they had it all worked out which uh you
know it just made me feel like maybe the
the answer is on a Showbiz level people
figure things out they do and and maybe
that's the answer in the Middle East is
we how do we turn this into Show
Business yeah you know and then
everyone's going to be like okay wait a
minute all right I can see I see how we
can do this I see how we can figure this
out well it's so funny that you say that
because there we had these these kids
um who came from this area called Janine
which is one of the most dangerous areas
in the West Bank there's there's a lot
um of kind of you know there's there's
truly a lot of unjust violence happening
and these kids have this thing called
Freedom theater in the middle of all of
it and they're working on becoming
actors they don't it's like and it's
unbelievable they send in these audition
tapes and these kids are like I'm gonna
be a big actor and it's like wow and we
saw these two kids we fell in love with
work they got to be in the show and we
were gonna go and shoot by them then
this happens and we can't and so we had
to ask the government for a visa to get
them in to Jerusalem and everyone's like
this is impossible not going to happen
and somehow it did so I mean to your
theory that somehow Show Business makes
things work like these kids have never
gotten a Visa their whole life to come
over and then this kid came and he went
to the Sea for the first time like he
went to the water for the first time in
his life oh wow to shoot our thing and
he was like this is the best week of my
life shooting this TV show and there was
this really interesting thing that did
happen where you're there and you're
just seeing all the pieces work even
though this horrific thing happened
while we were there everyone kept cool
everyone was like okay we're gonna just
figure this out somehow the Visa is
still cleared like all these things that
you would think wouldn't be able to
happen happen and I agree with you when
you're there on the ground you're seeing
people speaking you know like one of our
guys is this driver Palestinian dude he
speaks English Arabic Hebrew and a bunch
of everyone so he's like he knows Hebrew
and he's walking around he's speaking to
a to a Israeli soldier in Hebrew and
then they're they're going somewhere
else and then he's speaking Arabic and
and you just see this desire to keep
making things work and somehow pep in
the step and somehow just like we're
gonna get through this we're gonna
figure it out right and and I don't know
if you felt this but I walked away and I
was just I was inspired you know I left
thinking one thing I think is I
My Philosophy I've done all these travel
shows gone to these different countries
and ended up with this philosophy that I
don't
I think there's a tendency for people to
want to make things simple and there's a
lot of pundits that like to say it's
easy you know uh whether it's in America
they like to say it's an easy choice and
I like and I like to point out that
things are very complicated things are
extremely complicated and so that's been
a little bit of bone of contention to
mine is when you go and you see that it
there's there is no simple truth that
explains it's very it's so complex that
uh when people act like no no this is
easy on one side of the other I think I
get offended by that
um yeah because it feels to kind of just
like underwrite a bunch of real
complicated human experiences right so
here you know this is what you do okay I
got it now next what do we got next you
know and I think well clearly they do it
it's a big problem in American politics
now is Everyone likes to think it's you
know this is so simple yeah my side's
right and your side's wrong and
that's uh that's not always the case you
know well I've you know my uh my
therapist will say a lot of times
um things are simple but that doesn't
mean they're easy right like sometimes
the hardest things are the simple things
right you know and that's where a lot of
the complications come in in that vacuum
of like well it should be you know we
why can't like it is a very hard thing
to achieve Simplicity even at home right
you know with your family to be able to
do the simple thing and and so I think
that the thing that gives me hope when
I'm there is seeing certain microcosms
of how people deal with each other that
can be inspiring but you know and and I
think my hope comes from like okay what
if we were able to get enough microcosms
right that the macrocosm would solve
itself and I actually think that
probably is like in in many ways a
pattern that would work but it's really
hard to nail a microcosm it's really
hard to nail just what's going on in
your own house right well that's I think
again going back to your shelled that
it's all about this is a family and
years and years and years ago when I
worked on The Simpsons uh I remember
thinking um my job here is just to think
of the funniest I'm going to think of
the funniest jokes I can and the
funniest situations I can and then uh
sort of hearing the people that that ran
the show said you know you have to
remember first and foremost they're a
family and I thought what
true level I'm gonna write the craziest
Mr Burns jokes you've ever seen I don't
care about that but they were right it's
first and foremost a family which is
what makes it work I think the reason
that your show has an impact when you
watch it is because I relate to I relate
to this family because it's really not
that different from any other family
yeah you know in in there are specific
things that of course very different but
that's why I'm there that's why I'm
invested is because like the episode you
made about your mom and her struggles
and she becomes a Lyft driver and just I
felt terrible for her I feel like no
one's seeing her no one's no one's
taking care of her you blow her off uh
for dinner you're out the door and she's
made this great dinner and you suck by
the way yeah yeah you're a bad guy yeah
yeah why did you do that I got mad at
you when you did that I'm like can't you
see yeah yeah I know your mother made
that nice meal and then you're like Mom
I gotta go I gotta meet my friends and
she just the door shuts and she's there
with a lot of food and she's alone I
mean you Mommy I know I'm sorry but
come on so many people you know will say
that to me like man I hate your
character but I think the most
heartbreaking line in that
um in in that scene to me was in the way
she delivered it she really made it even
better than it had been written but she
was like
you know I think my Facebook's not
working like I haven't gotten any likes
you know and I was like oh man that's
art like like that's always the hardest
how do you explain to someone yeah it's
like no you just you just didn't get any
likes you just didn't get any likes so
like and I think there's so much in that
episode where like and in those Dynamics
where it's like man we we feel everyone
feels this thing for their mothers on a
level even when the relationships are
complicated where whether you feel it a
lot or you see it in a glimpse or you
have a window of looking at your mother
and being like man she gave up a lot
yeah she gave up a lot and especially in
a time where we crave our individuality
And We crave our our self-expression in
in this era you know and then you're
looking at that you know a mother and
you go wow she she put it all you know
she put it all to the side for for us
and I think again that creates a little
bit of the show so much of it is about
obviously it's not just even just
spiritual guilt it's even that kind of
guilt you know that guilt that you can
have you know in in just what was
sacrificed for you and and I think in
the design of of also yeah making his
character I mean you know this because
you
um
you know you you walk and it's different
in a way because I made a fictional
thing but like I think the level of
self-deprecation that's in your humor
and the way that things roll off of you
is
I just have always felt like you're you
you present in in a way where it's not
this like look at me look at me like
kind of thing and I think it's it's it's
why you're one of the greats and then
when I was hugging you earlier when you
were kind of like it was a bit of like a
stronghold you had me I wouldn't like a
test I wouldn't like yeah you wouldn't
let go and I felt it in that too where I
was like yeah this guy is like a real
dude I love this and and I think
in making the show for me I didn't want
to make this character was like oh
Robbie the hero look at him he's just
struggling I and I think sometimes I've
gotten a little bit of the criticism
that I go too far but I really I like
leaning into those
um more you know lower self parts of me
on screen and I like leaning more into
the like I don't want you to think oh
this is a hero I'm rooting for him I'd
rather you know put my character in a
position where yeah he he's really he's
dealing with his ego and and it feels uh
a lot easier for me to live with like I
just don't even think I'd have fun
making the show if it was just like oh
man he tried his best but he's such a
sweetheart and right you know like it
was just something about that Rings
Falls to what I like about comedy yeah
I'm like yo comedy's where I get to be a
little like I I I this is the part
of me that like I have fun being a
little yeah and it's also I
think the life-saving thing for me in
comedy has been I was raised to be very
I'm supposed to be you know polite
there's all these rules that you're
supposed to follow and I I think I was a
good rule follower and then I found this
world where you can act in the most
insane Manner and it's part of your job
and everyone's like good job what are
you talking about I just I totally you
know I I screamed at Jordan schlansky
you know this guy that works for us uh
and uh or I threw him through a window
and they're like I know it was fantastic
it was a great great job and but part of
that I think is how you were raised
because it's like just on a real bass
based level it's so clear that you're
such a good boy you know like I think so
it's so clear that's why you do that
stuff and then it's like oh I get the
spirit that it's in right you know and
there is comedy I watch where I'm like
oh this is just mean and I don't like it
and I'm just like oh I don't care about
this like yeah I'm not interested in
this right this is I think this person
is mean I think this person is just
taking the on everybody and then
there's just something with with the
things I like where I it is it's like
you were raised to people and I think
you it's so clear that you are and
that's why you're able to do all that
stuff and it's so funny well I hope so
but
until someone says no wait a minute I
think he is an